this Rocky Hill is being prepped to
House people displaced by the earthquake
the construction workers have laid the
foundation
they say the first section of the 310
structures will be completed in four
months
two kilometers away hanum Shakir lives
in a Tan City
she lost four of her relatives in the
quakes
she desperately needs to move into a new
house
we want the government to give us a
house we've received little AIDS so far
we have no other options if we at least
get a house we can mourn in a decent way
in her Village tons of houses have
collapsed or have been heavily damaged
The Village used to have a population of
90 people one third of whom have died
more than 2 million people in Turkey are
now living intense cities across 11
provinces
people want to move into houses as soon
as possible and officials say providing
permanent accommodation is a priority
but for many experts here laying the
foundations now may be risky because of
aftershocks
in less than two months turkey will hold
general elections
yunus kachmas is an engineer living in
karaman maharash he's worried that the
government is rushing into construction
to avoid the political cost of
earthquakes he says dividing a fragment
in the city without a master plan will
result in City losing its Center
our main concern is that as aftershocks
still continue the ground is not stable
and cement will get cracked but even
more importantly if we don't act
according to a master plan the city will
gradually get closer to the fault lines
again a proper planning is needed
because of the massive destruction
katmas estimates half a million new
buildings will need to be built in
disaster areas despite the government's
promise to complete this large
undertaking in a year he believes it
will take much longer to rebuild the
devastated cities
Southeastern turkey